nearly everyone has struggled in some
shape or form during the pandemic a new
report from the cdc shown in 2020 drug
overdose fatalities hit the highest
number ever recorded
madison kimbrough went to a facility
today they specialize in addressing
trauma and loss
she's live in our newsroom with that
story hi madison yes over at las vegas
therapy this is the busiest they've ever
seen and while the pandemic recedes
we're still dealing with this overdose
crisis as there is still so much
uncertainty
and stress making it very hard for the
majority of people
to cope according to the cdc drug
overdose deaths rose by close to 30
percent
in the united states in 2020 hitting the
highest number
ever recorded now here in nevada the
department of health and human services
reports that accidental drug overdose
deaths in nevada
increased by 37 percent from the first
half of 2019 to the first half of 2020.
now also in our state fentanyl overdoses
nearly tripled
in the first part of 2020. many who use
these drugs start out with prescriptions
and then the addiction takes off from
there
opioid use and abuse oftentimes it can
be
something that may be prescribed as an
injury
and then you know because there may be
those you know co-occurring mental
health
you know disorders or conditions then
that becomes
you know a gateway now as for ways to
help reporting any type of behavior that
seems off is vital
and surrounding yourself with people is
also key now crisis support services of
nevada
is available to help the number is on
your screen along with las vegas therapy
like we mentioned and several other
specialists across the valley
reporting live in the newsroom madison
kimbrough 8 news now